i
[Música]
a
la falta de reconocimiento del
matrimonio homosexual es
inconstitucional lo aclarado esta semana
un tribunal de sapporo con una sentencia
que supone el primer paso hacia su
legalización será un camino largo y
pedregoso porque exigirá la aprobación
de una ley pero la comunidad lgtb te
juzgó la jornada ya como histórica la
sentencia llega después de que 13
parejas homosexuales presentaran una
denuncia por discriminación el día de
san valentín de 2019 alegando que no
podían disfrutar de derechos como el de
heredar el tribunal les da la razón y se
espera que influya en los casos
pendientes japón es el único país del g7
que no reconoce los matrimonios
homosexuales y de hacerlo se convertiría
en el segundo de asia hasta ahora sólo
los admite taiwán una democracia
ejemplar en materia de derechos civiles
y que a pesar de eso tuvo que vencer
todas las reticencias conservadoras
antes de aprobarlo en 2019
[Música]
el grupo de la comunidad lgtb y que más
sufren irán son los homosexuales por un
lado están las autoridades especialmente
la policía que nos puede atacar en el
espacio público o entrar a sus casas
muchas veces los puede tener no por
acusados de homosexualidad pero sí de
dañar la tranquilidad en el espacio
público y también por sus familias que
los acusaban de deshonra de dañar la
imagen de la familia nos ponen al lado
muchas veces los de seriedad y no les
vuelven a hablar estaba totalmente en
contra en lo que pasa con los
transexuales que están permitidos en
irán después de una factura de la cato
la joven y 1979 incluso después de un
examen psicológico el estado puede
ayudar a financiar la operación de
cambio de sexo y también de cambio de
identidad de estas personas pero esto
también tiene problemas porque muchos
homosexuales no ven otra salida que
cambiarse de sexo algo que no quieren
hacer de antemano trayendo grandes
consecuencias mentales
[Música]
sudáfrica es el único país del
continente africano donde es legal el
matrimonio igualitario y después de la
caída de la parta y la nueva
constitución sudafricana sería la
primera en el mundo en prohibir la
discriminación a los homosexuales
más adelante en 2006 sudáfrica se
convertiría en el quinto país en aprobar
el matrimonio para personas del mismo
sexo durante la parte de la
homosexualidad de criminalística hasta
quedar hasta con siete años de prisión
pero hoy en día en áreas urbanas
especialmente aquí la ciudad del cabo y
especialmente aquí en el barrio de green
point es donde nos encontramos ahora se
presenta una amplia oferta para la
comunidad lgtb y del mundo incluso se
ofrecen paquetes turísticos que buscan
atraer a miembros de esta comunidad a
visitar la ciudad sin embargo en las
áreas menos favorecidas especialmente en
la periferia urbana se presentan aún
grandes desafíos para la comunidad lgtb
y sobre todo cuando hablamos de
episodios de violencia homofóbica y de
altas tasas de vih sudáfrica también es
un centro receptor de inmigrantes el fpv
y de países de áfrica subsahariana donde
la homosexualidad es criminalizada entre
los cuales se encuentra en zimbabwe
uganda y tanzania
[Música]